buzzers it is a bold new world
yesterday President Trump made history
no not by legalizing big-game hunting on
the White House lawn he did that weeks
ago you just didn't notice now I'm
talking about his trip to Singapore for
a historic peace summit with North
Korean dictator Kim Jong hoon god what a
win it felt so good to see president
Trump out there with Kim our proud flag
mixed up with theirs and some sort of
red white and blue ideological blur you
can barely tell where America ends in
the authoritarian regime begins I tell
you this meeting was bold unprecedented
upsetting decades of both geopolitical
and haircut norms now of course the
liberals want you to think that Trump is
in over his head but the president is
not out of his depth he splashing around
in the deep end of the pool with the
confidence of a drunk cousin who just
yelled at how hard can swimming be the
truth is this summit was a victory but
don't tell the crime left that it seems
like Kim got a lot more out of this
meeting than Trump pledges of nuclear
disarmament remain vague despite the
declarations of a new friendship Donald
Trump spoke about this as a
comprehensive agreement in fact it's a
series of four short bullet points kim
jeong-hoon he wanted the photos the seat
at the table he wanted the legitimacy
that came with the event Kim Jong moon
got it all for actually doing nothing oh
all for nothing might I remind you about
the declaration of friendship that's the
international version of a free massage
coupon I give those all the time thanks
but no thanks anti Trump / media if I
want to know how the meeting went I'm
gonna talk to someone who is actually in
the room it's like how if I want to know
how a blender works I'm going to read
some elitist Amazon review I'm going to
stick my hand in the blender and find
out I'm not an idiot
great really princess with me a lot of
progress really very positive and I
think better than anybody pretty
expected top of the line yes yes oh you
know something went great when you can't
stop insisting how great it went when I
lost my virginity I spent four days
talking about it
incidentally that also ended with the
declaration of friendship
the fact is Trump has the unique skills
necessary to connect with kim jeong-hoon
the left likes to call him the reality
show president but guess what kim
jeong-hoon is a reality show dictator
he's got style a flair for the dramatic
his whole country is just one big
performance fake newspapers fake store
fronts fake amusement parks North Korea
is basically a shitty less confusing
West world and when a reality show
dictator meets with the reality show
president you don't make a peace
agreement you pitch a crossover episode
and the pitch took no time at all
president Trump and North Korean leader
Kim jong-un shook hands right at the
start of this one-day summit they then
met privately only joined by their
respective interpreters for about 45
minutes yes he got his elevator pitch to
a tight 45 minutes which is exactly how
long an elevator ride takes in North
Korea the 45 minutes is plenty of time
to end 70 years of nuclear tension with
30 plus minutes left over for Trump to
walk Kim through his electoral college
win the president Trump didn't forget
the first power play of any Hollywood
pitch meeting say yes to everything
president Trump making a massive
concession agreeing to stop joint
military exercises between the United
States and South Korea we will be
stopping the war games which will save
us a tremendous amount of money plus I
think it's very provocative
yes yes I agree defending an ally in the
region is an incredibly provocative idea
we gave that up days ago and did this
major concession catch some people
off-guard
sure but Trump knows how to play the
reality game no spoilers when it came to
shutting down peacekeeping military
exercises he didn't mention any of this
to the Pentagon or our South Korean
allies
it's called dramatic tension vulnerable
South Korean citizens come on like the
real tension you're now feeling only
it's dramatic but Trump wasn't done
because he knows pitching is also about
flattery the man you met today Kim
jong-un as you know has killed family
members has starved his own people why
are you so comfortable calling him very
talented well he is very talented
anybody that takes over a situation like
he did at 26 years of age and is able to
run it and run it tough yes classic move
compliment the other guys big strong
glaring human rights violations sexy
remember you're not here to condemn
atrocities you're here to make a hit
preferably not Guam and Trump knows you
can't make a hit without a beautiful
setting they have great beaches you see
that whenever they're exploding their
cannons into the ocean right I said boy
look at that wouldn't that make a great
condo think of it from a real estate
perspective yes
finally someone who can look past the
war crimes and see the real value in the
beaches they happened on that gulag
abodes would make a sweet indoor wave
pool
obviously I'm sold and take it from me
I've pitched Hollywood a lot of reality
shows house poachers honeymoon swappers
get--let's tattoo this dog
we're late none of them have been picked
up yet but Rob and I both understand
something when you're pitching a project
you got to go above and beyond your
pitch has to have a sizzle like a trump
steak exposed to open air that's why I
was so excited to hear that the
president wasn't afraid to pull out all
the stops without an iPad and play for
the leader of North Korea a video that
the White House actually made and I
cannot stress enough how amazing and
actually from the White House
this video is seven billion people in
heaven planet Earth only the very few
will make decisions or take actions that
renew their homeland and change the
course of history a new world can begin
today one of friendship respect and
goodwill when a man is presented with
one chance that may never be repeated
destiny pictures presents a news story a
new beginning one of peace
men to leaders one destiny yes yes gets
me so hyped what does it take to achieve
world peace
apparently five stallions nine sunrises
one extremely generic dunk Sylvester
Stallone I mean I'm at max peace right
now but go ahead actual video from the
White House taught me off will this
leader choose to advance his country and
be part of a new world be the hero of
his people will he shake the hand of
peace
featuring president Donald Trump
and chairman kim jungeun in a meeting to
remake history
the future remains to be written oh
brilliance the future remains to be
written I didn't know trump university
offered a masters in screenwriting so
don't let us down Kim keep on shaking
this hand of peace and if the world
can't get behind this incredible
television event then let's tattoo this
dog the fight continues good you hid
down here with a real truth lies you
want to help me defeat the globalists
and stay on the inside click and
subscribe and help me defeat them
because following me on my youtube
channel makes you a leader it tracks
trust me